some more breaking news this time a
tweet from the chief whip Simon Hart
saying that they've removed the whip
immediately from conservative MB MP
Andrew he writes Andrew bridgen has
crossed a line causing great offense in
the process as a nation we should be
very proud of what's been achieved
through the vaccine program the vaccine
is the best defense against covid that
we have misinformation about the vaccine
causes harm and costs lives and
therefore removing the whip from Andrew
brigdon with immediate effect pending a
formal investigation of course this
relates to the fact that he has been
sharing various information questioning
the safety of various uh covert related
vaccines in recent weeks not just on
Twitter in various places he has had the
whip removed with immediate effect
pending a Further full investigation by
the chief whip Simon Hart and Liz Bates
joins me here on set with some reaction
to this but also just remind us what led
us to this position in the first place
so Andrew bridgen has previously spoken
out against the covid vaccine he's a
skeptic on this issue he tweeted
um basically comparing the covert
vaccination program to the Holocaust
that prompted that prompted as you could
imagine some pretty serious criticism
one of his own colleagues Simon Clark
tweeted in response this is disgraceful
and then quite quickly after that we've
had this reaction from the chief whip
Simon Hart who has said Andrew bridgen
has crossed a line causing great offense
in the process as a nation we should be
very proud of what has been achieved
through the vaccination program the
vaccination is the best defense against
covid that we have misinformation about
the vaccine causes harm and costs lives
and so he is currently suspended he is
not currently a sitting conservative MP
and and in terms of uh how we got to
this point of having the whip suspended
you mentioned these tweets over the last
two or three hours as he said quote in
one as one consultant cardiologist said
to me this is the biggest crime against
humanity since the Holocaust and in
doing so retweeting an article from Zero
Hedge that questioned the safety of of
the vaccines that clearly the moment
that he's been seen to cross the line in
the eyes of the chief whip though he's
been questioning the the safety of these
vaccines for quite some time he has and
he's been moving uh further and further
towards this position if you like he is
in terms of his political leanings he is
a an Ardent brexiteer part of the ERG
but he's often he takes it his own
position on things he can be quite uh
controversial quite contrarian if you
like and he has been throughout covid a
lockdown skeptic a vaccine skeptic and
now his position seems to have hardened
even further and for the conservative
party this is a line that has been
crossed we will see of course if there's
any mention of this is so much on the
agenda in prime minister's questions
which uh is of course coming up in about
35 minutes time which we'll have a live
here on Sky News Liz for now thanks so
much